kim kardashian says she would do
anything to stay young
but no really anything they would say
that was like
so inappropriate
while chatting with the new york times
the reality star reveals the length
she's willing to go to for youthful
looks
kim kicks off the interview by saying
quote i'll try anything that's the
beauty of it then she gets a little
specific and with a side of tmi
kim says quote if you told me that i
literally had to eat poop every single
day and i would look younger i might i
just might i mean i think you have to do
whatever you're comfortable with and kim
is living very comfortable as a beauty
mogul according to the article kim's net
worth is estimated to be around a
billion dollars
that's thanks to her many beauty and
fashion ventures over the years the
latest of which is skin kim's new
skincare line if the name sounds
familiar it's because it seems like a
wordplay off of kim's successful
shapewear and clothing brand skims
i think my mission in launching
skin is just that i really
have always been this girl that loves to
share my tips and my tricks with people
as a key figure in the beauty industry
for over a decade kim isn't afraid to
admit her appearance takes a lot of work
she explains to the outlet so many
people want to act like they don't care
about how they look i'm not acting like
it comes easier or it's all natural you
don't just wake up and use whatever you
wake up you use ingredients the prp
facials stem cell facials lasers all of
that is work
as kim tells it when it comes to beauty
tips sharing is caring
what i've always been really
into and what i've always loved and what
i really feel like my brand is
is taking
things that i've learned along the way
whether it's been from top facialists or
chemists or dermatologist
and giving you guys my secrets that i've
learned like i would give my sisters and
this is similar to what kim told et back
in 2017 around the time her little
sister kylie jenner was on her way to
her own billion dollar empire are you
competitive about who can find the best
bronzer and the best product you know
what we're not really competitive and
it's crazy because
we're in the same business but i think
we have really different products and we
really work at that together um i've
always loved beauty she loves beauty
it's her life
i learned so much from her and yeah i
really do um
we just talked she's
she's so
like knows what she wants and is in the
field and i'm um
like i love getting her advice on things
so we work really well together and
there's really no competition
[Music]
you